No injury, thankfully, and that's why I took a step back...
...because I didn't want to do something silly out there and get injured.
So, I thought it was best if these girls took over...
...and did the rest of the job, which they absolutely did.
They're Olympic silver medalists now, and they should be really proud of themselves...
...for how well they did last minute, having to go in.
It's been really stressful, this Olympic Games.
I think, just as a whole, not having an audience there.
A lot of different variables going into it.
It's been a long week.
It's been a long Olympic process.
It's been a long year.
So, just a lot of different variables, and I think...
...we're just a little bit too stressed out,...
...but we should be out here having fun, and sometimes, that's not the case.